[Music]
Jason what's up are you doing here it's
Batman he's in trouble
Gotham's gotten worse
Commissioner Gordon's dead Batman
smelling the feathers Joker if you need
to come back to Gotham and Gilligan sue
not to do it
Bruce Wayne's not my responsibility
he saved you dick
what if you're the last person on earth
who can save him
conscience in a regards
he's the only hero the Gotham has left
she goes bad the city goes down
Jesus
this wasn't justice this was impressive
there's nothing how many more
it has to be stopped
[Music]
he chose to embrace his darkness rather
than denied
this is what you've always wanted
wanted me to give into the darkness it's
become you
a murderer let's end this
hey everybody its charlie we have to
break down this Titans Batman footage
they have finally done the thing I think
I predicted a long time ago that they
might have Batman on the TV show there
were a lot of rumors it seemed like they
were building up to that but there are a
lot of shows like flash arrows seems
like they're going for really easy slam
dunks and then they Zig when they zag
and they don't end up doing the really
big thing that you hope for so I believe
that this is the first genuine adult TV
Batman in a real Batman costume on
screen since Adam West so don't worry if
you're confused about what's going on
and you have not been watching Titans
this season you just been watching my
highlight videos I'll explain what's
going on with weird looking flip flops
Robin who's in what seems like the
suburbs in this crazy dark version of
reality if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I'll explain schedule stuff at the end
of the video too because Young Justice
season 3 is starting in a couple weeks
so quick catch up if you have not
watched episode 10 careful for spoilers
because there's a really big cliffhanger
and this trailer is just so different
that it seems like there's a time jump
or reality is being warped in some dark
way so at the end of episode 10 Raven is
tricked by her mother into bringing
Trigon to our world he's being played by
Seamus Denver and he gives us really
evil smile Robin tries to enter this
barrier this around their house and just
disappears as if reality has been
changed around where Raven is living so
there's this crazy unexplained jump in
the story between smiling Trigon and
flip flops Robin maybe there's like a
little time jump but reality has also
been fundamentally altered because
everybody has a lot of costume changes
and the way they're presenting Batman in
this is so dark that it just seems off
the rails crazy
so Jason Todd rolls up in this footage
and tells Nightwing you need to come
back Batman has gone off the rails
he is taking down everyone it's no
longer justice we're at darkest timeline
scenario and it all sounds like
something that Trigon is doing to
reality like covering the world in his
darkness which they talked about during
episode 10 that is why Starfire came to
Planet Earth because she learned about
the prophecy of Trigon her people knew
that after Trigon was done taking the
earth for his own he would move on to
other plan
their planet would eventually burn so
she was preemptively coming to try and
stop Trigon from coming to this reality
so that's why they were hyping up
Starfire versus Raven in the last
episode there was a really cool Wonder
Woman lasso of truth moment with Donna
Troy I am so glad that they went full-on
lasso and they're actually using the
same special effects that they used for
the Wonder Woman movie you find out the
Commissioner Gordon is apparently dead
it sounds like it might be the Joker or
one of the other main Batman villains
because then there's this montage of
dead Batman villains the one holding the
coin seems like it's meant to be
two-face there's one with question mark
tattoos that I'm assuming is supposed to
be their version of the Riddler
then we finally see our first real legit
version of a TV Joker
I know Gotham's TV show has been playing
around with that character in roundabout
ways but like this is telling you this
is the adult Joker there's like no
alternate personality no weird twin
stuff going on it's a genuine Joker as
you would think of him in one of the
Batman movies and we finally get our TV
Batman going to town on everyone in his
bat suit this is what it looks like way
more heavily armored this is what his
batarangs look like just eviscerating
everyone in the Batcave and these are
police officers so we think very clearly
like what they're setting up here is is
that Trigon has somehow altered the
world and if you've ever saw that
animated Justice League vs Teen Titans
movie they kind of do a version of that
so like Superman goes crazy but the way
they visualized that is that he has like
the Trigon looking eyes when he's being
possessed by trigons darkness there's
some significant changes for Starfire
like she has black straight hair she's
not wearing any special makeup or
jewelry she still has her powers because
she uses them in the Batcave here so her
hair still glows a little red when they
used those effects but it almost seems
like she's a completely different
character like she looks nothing like
the Starfire that we saw at the end of
episode 10 Titans has been really dark
this season so sometimes it is kind of
hard to tell like are they trying to say
this is really happening or is this just
happening in someone's head and that's
why it's so over-the-top dark the fact
that Batman is killing police officers
in the Batcave and they blow up Wayne
Manor just kind of hypes up the fact
that this is definitely some a mine
space crazy
Trigon trick like this isn't the true
genuine version of Batman that's doing
this what they're really setting up with
all this is his turn
Nightwing like he's trying to save
Batman from the edge of darkness find a
better way this whole season is about
him leaving behind his dark past and
finding a better way that better way is
the Nightwing identity he even had a
conversation with Donna Troy about
taking a new identity who should I be
what should my name be I'm not gonna be
Batman
don't be Batman be someone else who I
don't know and they just kind of leave
it hanging there like he just hasn't
come to the conclusion that Nightwing
will be that new persona that he takes
on so I'll be really interested to see
how they justify the Nightwing name
because Nightwing and flame bird
characters are very critical to that and
they haven't done those yet on the TV
show so they'll have to have some other
way of explaining that they've also been
foreshadowing him getting the Nightwing
suit the last couple of episodes like he
destroyed the last Robin costume the old
one Jason Todd was making fun of how
outdated it was and how cool the
brand-new costumes were so maybe he
saves Batman from The Edge of Darkness
and as a way of thanking him like you
brought me back thank you so much dick
and he gives him the Nightwing costume
like here this is a shiny new costume to
go with your new identity in your new
ethos there's a lot of stuff that we
could say about the Titans TV show I
feel like they've done a lot of good
things this season but it's been kind of
all over the place and just way too dark
in moments so I feel like there's some
creative things that they need to tune
behind the scenes before season 2 stars
so after the finale I'll do like a whole
season review where we talk more about
that there's a lot of stuff we needed to
talk about because of all the other
shows that are coming to like they
finally cast all the swampthing
characters we have a bunch of Justice
Society characters that are coming to
the universe as well what's happening
later today is I'm working on my
spider-man into the spider-verse
post-credit scene video that should post
tonight if you're a big Young Justice
fan quick reminder they're launching
season 3 on the DC streaming service
January 4th that's a Friday and they're
doing three episodes per week till they
burn through the first 12 to 13 episodes
of season 3 the second half of the
season will premiere later in the summer
and will comprise a separate our season
3 is 26 episodes total but I think
they're just breaking it into different
arcs and across the year so we'll talk
more about that when they drop more
footage flash arrow and all the other DC
TV shows are on
so there'll be some bonus videos
happening for that stuff to leave all
your requests in the comments below
click here for my non-spoilery aquaman
review and click here for my brand-new
reverse flash trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight